well denise safe and free was the focus
of today's covet call with health
officials they say children make up a
big portion of our population which is
why they want them protected from this
and other viruses
covet 19 vaccines have arrived in nevada
for children ages 5 to 11 years old
health officials estimating about 277
thousand children in the state are
eligible for the shot and more than 230
providers are ready to administer them
over 6 million kids they say have been
infected by covet 19 since the start of
the pandemic which not only affects
their health but their education and
day-to-day activities local pediatrician
terence mcallister says parents need to
act fast to get their children
vaccinated before the holidays we warn
parents whenever we give their children
vaccines that they should expect a
chance for some mild side effects the
next day or two and so it's quite
possible your child may be not feeling
well the day after the vaccine and the
studies do show that the chance for the
side effects is higher with the second
dose mcallister says kids can expect to
have a fever or soreness after getting
the vaccine similar to other vaccines
they stress with the cold months
approaching indoor gatherings will
increase and the risks as well
we'll remind her that the covet 19
vaccine is free however parents are
encouraged to book an appointment check
out eightnewsnow.com for all those
details christian gossett is live local
now